and now please welcome bay area artist
linda gas take it away
thank you for having me here
this is a story about how an
experimental temporary land art
installation turned into a permanent
living artwork through the power of
community engagement
i'm an environmental activist and an
artist and i combine the two to make
artwork about climate change water and
land use my approach is to use beauty to
encourage people to look at the hard
issues we face i'm inspired by the
connections between humans and the water
and the land that we need to survive
several years ago i was awarded an
artist residency and i ventured outside
of my comfort zone to create create a
community engaged artwork in a new open
space park in a low-income racially and
culturally diverse city in the san
francisco bay area
the open space park is called cooley
landing and it's located in the city of
east palo alto
this is a bird's eye view of coulee
landing today but this peninsula of land
hasn't always been here
200 years ago the area was lush wetlands
but from 1932 to 1960 those wetlands
were filled with garbage when it was a
san mateo county landfill
lead mercury pcbs and other toxins were
all dumped here
today coulee landing is a new public
park the toxic landfill has been capped
with six feet of clean soil native
species have returned and they're
thriving and there's a beautiful new
education center
i invited the local community to
participate in creating a temporary land
art installation at cooley landing to
mark the former shoreline of the
wetlands with blue plastic survey
whiskers
the plan was to leave the installation
there for a month
i used this united states coastal survey
map of san francisco bay from 1857 to
locate the former shoreline of coulee
landing you can see the pier that was
the original cooley landing surrounded
by extensive wetlands
by placing this map over a recent
satellite image i could locate the
former shoreline relative to the present
day features the placement of the
installation is highlighted in blue and
it avoids habitat areas for endangered
species
on installation days i marked the former
shoreline with orange flagging tape
and then the community placed the blue
survey whiskers along this line by
hammering them into the ground with
five-inch nails
and people of all ages participated
here's a view of part of the final
installation the entire artwork is over
500 feet long and used 2 000 survey
whiskers
the community loved it and asked if i
could create a permanent installation
but without the plastic
i thought it would be really cool to
replace the survey whiskers with native
plants but i had no idea what to plant
so i consulted a local restoration
nonprofit and they suggested native
juncus
and together we created a new project
called the living shoreline
juncus is a reed that's blue green in
color and it grows upright so it was a
perfect replacement for the blue plastic
survey whiskers
it also has very good long-term survival
characteristics it's drought tolerant
and it grows in meadow or wetland
environments
coulee landing in nearby east palo alto
are vulnerable to the impact of sea
level rise so the adaptability of juncus
is important
as a wetland plant it helps reduce the
impact to sea level rise by absorbing
rising tides
over the past five years community
volunteers have helped to plant and
maintain the junkies
on weekends individuals and families
came out to plant
and many return to check on how it's
grown
during the week we invited school
classrooms to participate they ranged in
age from kindergartners to high school
students i was touched to see these
young children so focused on planting
the junkists they were so careful and
gentle with the plants
we also work with high school students
from six different local high schools
and we spent three hours giving them
hands-on experience with wetlands
restoration sea level rise science and
land art and everyone got to plant some
junkis
this is the installation a year after it
was planted i want to give a shout out
to my partners in this project
grassroots ecology the mid-peninsula
regional open space district and the
city of east palo alto and thanks to the
palo alto arts center as well
the other day i was looking at cooley
landing at google earth and i realized
that the installation is now visible
from space
it's been really rewarding to
collaborate with the community and with
living plants at this point nature is in
charge of the artwork and the junkist
continues to mature as you can see in
this recent photo if you like this
project and want to see more visit my
website or find me on social media thank
you so very much for this opportunity to
share this with you
linda thank you so much for being with
us today
what uh can you share another
of your favorite natural art pieces
ah that's a really good question this is
actually the first one that i've done
with plants i've done other land art
installations in the landscape using
textiles
and i really love collaborating with the
other species of plants so i want to do
more of that
if someone wanted to do a similar
project
how should they approach it
well it's really important to get the
community buy-in i did a lot of
presentations at city council meetings
and
collaborating with these different
government agencies in order to make it
happen
and so i think that's the most important
part and then also really understanding
the appropriateness of the plants that
you're using for the environment that
you're working in you don't want
something that's going to
take over
another landscape
you want it to be compatible with that
yeah so first community then plants
yes all right
well cool thank you so much linda
oh thanks for having me this is so nice
to be here